donc ben j'étais hyper jeune j'avais je
crois 12 13 ans et du coup ben pour la
la punir j'avais brûlé tous ses
habits première terriené ce soir l'ange
de la téléréalité qui s'est brûlé les
ailes
Nabila Nabila vous serit notre terrienne
du samedi 20h Nabila Benatia re
rebonsoir
vous êtes né le 5 février 1992 à ammas
en Haute Savoie votre père couti Benatia
d'origine algérienne qui était entré à
Genève à l'ONU comme stagiaire au
courrier et qui 20 ans plus tard y
occupait un poste de directeur belle
réussite non magnifique alors votre mère
marilus est assistante dans une banque
genevoise voilà alors durant vos 12
premières années tout va bien vous dites
j'ai même pas l'excuse de venir d'un
milieu pourri quoi bah non même pas les
premiers conflits familiaux apparaissent
à cause des interdits religieux le porc
l'alcool le maquillage les puis les
jupes un peu courte et puis les Kiss au
cinéma quoi c'est votre père était assez
dur quand même bah mon père il est
musulman pratiquant donc du coup enfin
ouais ça lui plaisait pas trop tout ça
alors quand une fille un peu dénudée
apparî à la télé il vous met la
la main sur les yeux quand même ouais il
se serait pas dit qu'un jour ce serait
moi la fille
desnudé à l'époque vos parents ne
cessent de s'engueuler j'imagine pour
pour les mêmes raisons bah ouais parce
que ma mère elle veut manger du porc et
lui il veut pas ah ou un truc comme ça
quoi et voilà et un jour votre mère
finit par prendre le large vous
choisissez de la suivre et votre petit
frère lui il reste avec son père voilà
alors vous reverrez pas votre père
pendant 5 ans quand même ouais c'est
long alors très vite votre mère cherche
à faire sa vie elle sort le soir vous
vous retrouvez souvent seulle à la
maison alors au début vous traînez à la
maison vous vous couchez tard mais
bientôt vous sortez en boîte enin
j'étouff chez moi et puis en plus je
suis toute seule donc j'en profite ouais
là vous tapez le look zonard quand même
survette casquette basket vous la jouz
un peu quand même
l'ancienne hein non mais parce qu'avant
enfin voilà j'étais un peu garçon manqué
ah ouais et du coup c'est dur à croire
et du coup j'en profiter quoi mais votre
mère elle rentrait dormir à la maison ou
pas non ah oui pas trop non alors tout
ça n'arrange pas vos relations avec
votre mère et un jour vous êtes
tellement énervé que vous brûlez sa
garde-robe avec une bombe de déodorant
et un briquet quoi qu'est-ce qu'elle
avait fait je l'attendais je l'attendais
elle rentrait pas et elle arrêtait pas
de me mettre des postites sur le frigo
j'arrive et en fait elle arrivait jamais
ouais donc ben j'étais hyper jeune
j'avais je crois 12 13 ans et du coup
ben pour la la punir j'avais brûlé tous
ces
alors à 15 ans votre mère en a marre
elle vous loue un studio vous obtenez
votre indépendance là vous faites des
petits boulots vous êtes vendeuse dans
une boutique de Fring au teste d'accueil
dans des salles de de fitness ça m'a
saoulé ouais et c'est là nabella que
vous faites votre première grosse bêtise
un dénommé Ludovic vous entraîne dans
une histoire d'arnaque bancaire alors je
va pas raconter c'est très compliqué
mais enfin vous ouvrez des comptes quoi
on m'a dit ouvre des comptes et tout tu
vas grave gagner des thunes et un an
plus tard vous passez la douane à
l'aéroport de Genève vous êtes arrêté
mais dur Menot garde à vue on vous
accuse d'ouverture de compte frauduleus
d'usurpation d'identité et vous vous
retrouvez dans un centre de détention
pour mineurs c'est où en Suisse il
s'appelle framboise ce centre ah c'est
joli ouais et c'était comment bah il
faisait hyper froid et
puis et puis j'avais hyper faim ouais
bon après vous sortez ou et vous
reprenez le le petit studio payé par par
votre mère un matin le téléphone sonne
c'est un casteur de l'amour est aveugle
émission en desmol TF1 ouais j'avais un
profil Facebook avec des photos hyper
stylées et du coup ouais bah il m'a
appelé vous avez 17 ans vous venez à
Paris en leur faisant croire que vous
êtes
majeur et là évidemment vous avez pas de
Sein à l'époque vous mettez du coton
dans votre soutieng merde euh ouais bah
oui parce que enfin je sais pas pourquoi
ça poussait pas à
l'époque donc vous faites l'amour est
aveugle en tant que familial vous
retournez à Genève vous faites opérer
ouais et vous passez quand même de 85B à
95D double
D alors quelques mois plus tard les
producteurs des Anges de la téléréalité
vous engagent pour la saison 4 ouais
c'est ça ha ouais alors vous ferez
ensuite la saison 5 cette fois en
Floride à Miami et c'est là que vous
rencontrez le fameux Thomas Vergara bah
je ça commence dans l'avion hein
l'histoire ouais j'ai un coup de [__]
ensuite évidemment les producteurs de
l'émission vont mettre ça en scène mais
ce qu'il faut dire c'est qu'au départ il
y a un vrai il y a un vrai crush quoi
bah ouais nous on on est tombé amoureux
l'un de l'autre et puis après ben il a
fallu montrer l'histoire au grand jour
donc c'était un peu relou au début ouais
puis après ben alors là c'est le début
évidemment de vos phrases cultes reste
dans ta jalousie moi je suis dans mon
jacuzzi que j'adore il y a aussi je suis
en train d'étudier la durée de vie d'un
glaçon au soleil que j'aime beaucoup et
l'IND dépassable évidemment non mais
allô quoi tu es une fille tu as pas de
shampoing allô voilà alors ça fait quand
même 10 millions de vues en quelques
jours sur internet le phénomène Nabila n
comme ça al le retour à Paris est
délirant tout le monde veut vous
interview ouais vous devenez une espèce
de de star quoi bah moi j'aime pas ce
mot parce que pour moi je seraai jamais
une star je suis juste moi-même
mais ouais voilà une Starlet alors le
problème c'est que très vite votre
notoriété se transforme en en bashing
non mais après j'avais l'impression qu'à
un moment donné genre il y a tout le
monde qui voulait donner son avis sur
moi et en général c'était des avis pas
hyper cool donc du coup ça c'était
c'était assez blessant et puis je sais
pas on arrivait sur un plateau puis on
mettait ma photo du genre bah qu'est-ce
que vous pensez d'elle et puis tout le
monde disait donnait son avis ouais
ouais CIT relou c'est vraiment un
déferlement de haine et vous vous
enfermez dans une chambre d'hôtel avec
Thomas tous les deux vous sortez plus
parce que dès que vous sortez ces
attroupements les Paparadis tout ça vous
sortez seulement pour défiler pour
Jean-Paul gotier qui vous adore pour
faire une téléréalité en famille autour
du monde avec votre fameuse grand-mère
Livia qui s'appelle alonabila c'est ça
donc du coup moi qui enfin qui regardait
beaucoup les Kardashian c'est vrai que
c'était un peu mon mon rêve mon rêve et
ben d'un coup on me sert mon rêve sur un
plateau on me dit bah voilà tu as ton
programme avec ta famille et tout et ben
maintenant il va falloir gérer être à la
hauteur quoi ouais ça s'appelle un
dynastye show effectivement alors c'est
là que Cyril Hanouna vous engage comme
chroniqueuse à Touche pas à mon poste
alors un soir vous dansez en maillot
avec Gill Verdez pourquoi vous êtes allé
danser en maillot avec g Verdes bah en
fait enfin je sais pas déjà enfin quand
on travaille là-bas et tout c'est hyper
cool mais voilà parfois on doit faire
des trucs des petits sketchs des trucs
comme ça donc du coup ben dès que je
mets un truc un peu sexy ça fait vite
too much donc mon mec il était pas
content VO bah il est pas content c'est
sûr quand vous revenez il vous fait une
scène mais il est très jaloux Thomas
très très jaloux vous disputez et à un
moment vous lui filez un coup de couteau
quoi tout le temps moi il me faisait des
reproches et puis moi je disais que
c'est pas de ma faute vous savez très
bien comment c'estit la télé enfin on
doit être cool faire un peu le show et
tout et lui ben il m'aime tellement que
enfin il dit c'est pas possible tu peux
pas me faire ça devant tout le monde moi
je passe pour un con les gens ils vont
dire que je laisse ma
femme faire voilà enfin faire la la [__]
moi vous connaissant j'aurais pensé que
vous l'attaqueriez avec une paire de l
Boutin je trouve que l'histoire du
couteau c'est c'est très bizarre alors
vous commencez évidemment par parler
d'une agression ensuite vous racontez
qu'il est tombé tout seul sur le couteau
enfin bon vous emmêlez dans les
explications comme un gosse et vous
finissez par avouer ouais alors en plein
milieu de la nuit comme si vous étiez
une dangereuse djihadiste vous êtes
placé en détention ouais dans une prison
pour femmes donc à Versailles là vous en
courz de 30 ans de prison hein c'est
c'est c'est très grave à l'époque alors
au début vous êtes à l'isolement dans le
quartier VIP ouais bah au début enfin je
réalise pas trop ce que je fais là parce
que il y a de jours avant j'étais en
face de Mimi mati on était là avec Cyril
et tout tranquille
et genre de jours après je me retrouve
avec des barreaux comme ça ouais enfin
on m'appelle par mon numéro vousz pas
prendre des douches donc vous restez une
semaine sans vous laver en plus mais je
voulais pas qu'on voit tout nu pour une
fois alors vous AZ pas la promenade et
le jour où vous y allez en fait
l'accueil est génial bah grave en fait
les fill sont super cool avec vous ouais
elles sont hyper gentil et puis elles me
disent bah voilà on est toutes dans le
dans le même trouinou donc on va être
solidaireou vous rencontrez palette
palette elle a tué son mari sa maîtresse
et elle fait des cookies pour tout le
monde ouais elle est trop gentille Po
est trop cool Polette voilà vous
rencontrer ralika aussi elle vous prête
du shampoing ouais par si vous êtes allé
là-bas sans shampoing bah je peux pas le
croire après 40 jours de prison vous
êtes libéré sous caution vous partez à
anemas che IIa votre grand-mère là vous
pensez qu' a une chose he c'est
retrouver Thomas retrouver Thomas mais
il est interdit de voir Thomas ouais ils
nous disent que ils sont bien d'accord
de me laisser sortir mais que il faut
pas que je parle à Thomas il faut pas
que je l'appelle et voilà et là vous
tenez plus le 31 décembre c'est le
réveillon bah ouais grave qu'est-ce
qu'on fait le réveillon il vient il
vient à Genève à la réserve donc au bord
du la clé vous vous racontez vos
dernières semaines vous dormez de temps
en temps ouais vous êtes resté 3 jours
enfermé dans cet hôtel alors là vous
devenez un couple hors la loi ouais
d'hôtel en hôtel la fuite permanente
commence on vous reconnaît partout tout
le monde vous balance enfin si vous êtes
des pour chasser quoi bah ouais genre
tous les Français ils prennent leur leur
iPhone et genre ils nous prennent tous
en photo comme ça al là vous vous ruinez
en perruque
ouais en chapeau en lunett est-ce que
vous avez essayé la burka
mais ça aurit fait plaisir à votre père
en même temps bah en fait j'en avais
acheté une pour pas lui donner raison
bah je l'ai pas mise ah ou alors
aujourd'hui la vie normale est un
lointain souvenir vous êtes toujours
traqué bah maintenant enfin je commence
à M faire ça va faire 4 ans et ben voilà
maintenant je je sais je sais gérer mais
c'est vrai que au début c'était pas
facile parce que j'étais personne et
tout d'un coup je suis devenue quelqu'un
et en plus pas forcément pour un truc
spécifique ou votre ambition en fait
c'est d'avoir une vie tranquille quoi
d'être marié d'avoir des enfants bah
maintenant ouaisfin je commence à y
penser pas maintenant parce que ça fait
des vergures et tout mais genre dans
quelques temps le 19 mai il y a le
procès là ouais vous avez peur grave ah
ouais bah ouais ça fait trop peur vous
risquez quoi je sais pas moi 6 mois de
tô c'est pas moi qui décide non non mais
moi je veux plus aller vous plus y aller
non vous étiez pas malheureuse en T ah
bon j'avais envie de sortir ah ouais don
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire pour vous
aider bah je sais pas on va
prier et pour être sûr de ne rien rater
de inarditbe abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce
bleu